and we told you last night how a mic
caught President Trump saying he plans
to release the house Intel committee's
controversial FISA memo earlier today
the White House chief of staff John
Kelly implied its release was
potentially imminent our national
security lawyers in the White House they
work for me
work for the president they're slicing
and dicing it looking at it so that we
know what what it means and what it
understands you see it I did what do you
think well let that'll be released here
pretty quick I think and Everett the
whole world can see it now Fox sources
are telling us it could be released
tomorrow and Adam Schiff just tweeted
out that it's his understanding that the
memo that was sent to the White House
for review was changed somehow by Devon
Nunez we haven't confirmed that and so
he's complaining that the whole
committee did not approve that that just
was tweeted a few moments ago but the
FBI is fighting back against the release
as we said earlier issuing a statement
today claiming the omissions of some
facts impact the memos accuracy you need
the full context they say let's discuss
all this with former Harvard Law
Professor Alan Dershowitz in Miami Beach
author of the best-seller trumped-up how
criminalization of pala the political
differences in dangers democracy and in
Atlanta Chris Walker he's a former head
of the FBI's Criminal Investigative
Division in Washington and someone who
personally knows director Christopher
ray and Special Counsel Bob Muller all
right professor let's start with you
here there seems to be these dueling
leaks coming out today some leaks of
information about Peter struck and the
timing of his knowledge of the emails
that were found the additional emails in
the fall of 2016 but for the moment
let's focus on the release of this memo
given what we know now do you believe
this memo should be released should see
the light of day absolutely and also the
contact should be released so both sides
have their say let the public decide
let's see the memo if people in the FBI
think it's out of context let them
release the rest of the material in
context and let the public decide as far
as you know the struck is concerned
and it just shows what happens when the
FBI doesn't have a clear rule that says
no discussing ongoing criminal
prosecutions except to say indictment no
indictment especially during an election
you know if in fact struck tried to
delay it it probably backfired because
if it had been released earlier then
maybe they would have been able to
decide there were no more classified
materials and they would have corrected
it earlier so whatever impacted on the
election this should never ever happen
and we have to have rules preventing it
from ever happening again Chris you know
Muller you know ray
Christopher Rea under some fire although
he was you know hugely praised by both
sides at his own confirmation as head of
the FBI and your sense of where this is
going tonight well as John Q citizen I
would love to see the memo I would love
to know if the FISA Court was misled I'd
love to know if the by so judge was
aware that if the dossier information
was included that it was paid for by a
political opponent but the FBI executive
in me or former executive in me says
let's play by the rules not like this
this is not how you release information
from from a partisan body like Congress
I just don't have any faith in
congressional committees I'm sorry there
they've got their own agenda and there's
a process for releasing Feiss
information I've used it it's not that
hard to use there's a right way to do
this and I just like to see it done by
the rules you get in trouble when you
start making up your own rules well what
happens when the FBI makes it I have to
tell you what happens a who's supposed
to do oversight of the FBI I have to
tell you Chris Congress does the
oversight of the FBI and while they're
amazing people at the FBI if there was a
political animus as pressor Dershowitz
has talked about on this show so often
under girding the start of this
investigation and the FISA application
itself we got a real problem on our
hands with politicizing law enforcement
in the United States and I'm a huge
defender of law enforcement so you got a
balancing act yeah follow the rules what
if the FBI wasn't following the rules
and they were off half-cocked professor
mm-hmm that's right now it's so
refreshing to hear conservative it's so
refreshing to hear conservatives and
Republicans questioning and overseeing
the FBI that's something that we
liberals did for years and years and
years now the Democrats are saying oh
the FBI is beyond reproach we should
never question law enforcement and the
Conservatives are saying well we need
transparency we need accountability look
everybody should be in favor of
accountability by the FBI and in my
experience at least 99% of the time when
people claim national security need for
censorship when it altom Utley gets
released it was not really so important
it was overstated look the movie the
post obviously the Pentagon Papers makes
that point the government got out in
front of the Supreme Court and said the
government the country would fall if the
Pentagon Papers were released and they
were released then of course only
positive came from it so in general I'm
in favor of disclosure and full
transparency and sure you follow the
rules but the rules or to err on the
side of disclosure rather than
suppression and just for clarity
purposes Adam shifts a tweet that just
was sent out discovered late tonight
that chairman Nunez made material
changes to the memo he sent to the White
House changes not approved by the
committee White House therefore
reviewing a document the committee has
not approved for release and he attaches
a copy of that document
no so that's Chris you can close it out
but you know you should you shouldn't if
that happened and I don't know if it did
or not
well you [ __ ] you can't materially
change the document that the committee
hasn't approved I would assume that
that's no no but we'll have to learn
more about that Chris you know Muller
you know Ray I you you also know the
facts as they've developed about the
agents and the Peter struck doing both
investigations Hillary email and an
Trump you have confidence in the outcome
of this investigation I do have
confidence in the outcome I know Chris
Rhea I think he's he deserves the
benefit of the doubt in this circuit
under these circumstances look I'm all
for disclosure the FBI is not
just snowflakes they can take criticism
they can take oversight they should be
transparent but in this case Chris has
come forward now he was approved with
the overwhelming vote of the Senate
let's give him the confidence let's give
him the credibility and let's let's go
with his recommendation at this point
and let's do it right if there's
misconduct there let's refer that to the
inspector they are doing it right I mean
you act as if I mean again I'm putting
aside this this tweet by ship they have
done it right correct me if I'm wrong
professor they went through the process
of the committee reviewing this document
reviewing its contents for national
security concerns chief of staff the
president are there FBI officials you
know read it over ray and now FBI
officials say no this is a great issue
of grave concern that seems like to me
it seems like a stretch but I don't know
you keep saying do it by the rules I
think they have followed the rules again
setting aside this tweet that I don't I
we can't we can't confirm just as never
that constitutionally the president has
the authority that the president has the
authority to class declassify anything
he is the ultimate authority on what can
be declassified and if he wants to see
the memo out nobody can really overrule
that to say all right and guys thanks so
much